[Music]  love injured  slower jinwu Yamamoto commish you can  shop Saikyo touch no Dory you achieve I  should know how are the suits the  traffickers in it I am mom Suja Captain  America come here no power to the  Kamisama full salad Brad Guido  how do buckets here oval sausage Jim  dishes your side are you know Cheney  touchable come there was an idea to  bring together a group of remarkable  people to see if we could become  something more so when they needed us we  could fight the battles that they never  could  [Music]  [Music]  in time you will know what it's like to  lose feel so desperately that you're  right yet to fail all the same  [Applause]  read it  run from it destiny still alive  [Music]  evacuate the city  engage your defenses  and get this man a sheet  [Music]  on isn't something one considers  imbalance in the universe  but this does put a smile on my face  [Music]  [Music]  who the hell are you guys  [Music]  [Music]